all right I have to ask you are in great
shape can you uh go through your diet
and exercise routine
I um
I do intermittent fasting so I eat
between I start at my first meal at
around noon
and then I try to stop eating at six
or seven
and then um I I I hike every day
morning evening in the morning I go to a
meeting first thing in the morning 12's
a meeting and then I go hike I've heard
and I hike uphill for a mile and a half
up and a mile half down with my dogs and
I do my meditations
and then I go to the gym and I go to the
gym for 35 minutes
I don't I do it short time I've been
exercising for 50 years
and what I found is it's sustainable if
you know if I do just the short periods
and I do four different routines at the
gym and I never relax at the gym I go in
there and I have a very intense exercise
and I lived you know I mean I I could
tell you what my routine is but I do
I do backs one day back just one day
legs and then a miscellaneous and I do
12 my first set of everything is is I
try to I try to reach failure at 12 reps
and then my fourth set of everything is
a strip set
um I do I take a lot of
um
vitamins I I can't even list them to you
here because I you know I I couldn't
even remember them at all but I take a
ton of vitamins and nutrients
I'm on an anti-aging protocol from my
doctor
that includes uh uh
um testosterone replacement
and uh but I don't take any steroids I
don't take any anabolic steroids or
anything like that and the
DRT I use is Is bioidentical to what my
body produced what are your thoughts on
hormone therapy in general
I've talked to a lot of doctors about
that stuff you know because I'm
interested in health
and I you know I've heard really good
things about it but I don't know I'm
definitely not an expert on it